dans notre rapport sénatorial porno
l'enfer du décor avec mes trois
collègues Cora porteurs Alexandra borque
Fontain Laurence Cohen et Laurence
Rossignol nous avons pour la première
fois dans l'histoire du Parlement
révélée les deux sous sordides de cette
industrie de la pornographie une
industrie qui génère des milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires chaque
année dans des conditions opaques une
industrie qui a fait de la
marchandisation du corps et de la
sexualité des femmes un business à
l'échelle mondiale la consommation de
porno aujourd'hui est massive elle
représente plus d'un quart de tout le
trafic vidéo en ligne dans le monde le
site pornhub cumule à lui seul plus de
40 milliards de visites annuelles et
près de 220 000 vidéos vues chaque
minute dans le monde notre rapport
dresse un tableau très sombre mais
réaliste des pratiques de cette
industrie violence systémique envers les
femmes exploitation de
économique et sociales acte de torture
et de barbarie les deux affaires
judiciaires en cours en France en
témoignent elles ne sont que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg nous appelons à
sortir de toute vision datée et édulcoré
du porno le porno aujourd'hui ce sont
majoritairement des contenus violents
dégradants humiliant tous ces contenus
sont facilement et massivement
accessibles aux mineurs deux tiers des
enfants de moins de 15 ans et un tiers
de moins de 12 ans ont déjà vu des
images pornographiques la délégation
porte unanimement 23 propositions pour
lutter contre les violences
pornographiques et leurs conséquences ma
question est la suivante madame la
Première ministre comment comptez-vous
vous en parlez de ces propositions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]